Trascrizione: Angela Di Croce
Revisore: Ysiana Agalliu
L'acqua sarà un giorno un combustibile.
L’idrogeno e l’ossigeno di cui è composta
offriranno una sorgente inesauribile
di luce e di calore.
L'idrogeno sarà il carbone del futuro.
Questo è quello che ci diceva Giulio Verne
nel 1874, 150 anni fa.
Anche io ho letto con coinvolgimento
i romanzi di Verne
Dalla Terra alla Luna,
20.000 leghe sotto i mari,
ma L’isola misteriosa e la prospettiva
di una fonte inesauribile di energia
mi ha sempre entusiasmato.
Quanti di voi hanno giocato
con una macchinina radiocomandata
prima delle batterie al litio?
Qualche minuto di divertimento
e poi nulla.
Questa delusione, assieme alla prospettiva
di una fonte inesauribile di energia
hanno fatto sì che fin da bambino
avessi deciso di occuparmi di idrogeno
e di farne il mio lavoro.
Ebbene, quello che ai tempi di Verne
e poi della mia adolescenza
era una visione fantastica,
è oggi un progetto condiviso dalla scienza
dalle autorità pubbliche e dall’industria.
Il problema è che l’idrogeno
non è una fonte di energia,
l’idrogeno è un vettore energetico.
Non è che lo troviamo
in una miniera come il carbone.
L’idrogeno sulla Terra bisogna generarlo.
E per generarlo serve energia.
E il sistema, il processo è verde, pulito
solo se questa energia
proviene da fonti rinnovabili
come il sole e il vento.
Ma il sole e il vento
possono veramente offrirci tutta l’energia
di cui abbiamo bisogno
per generare l’idrogeno?
Sì, come si vede da questa
enorme sfera gialla alle mie spalle.
Il suo volume rappresenta l’energia
che ogni anno la Terra riceve dal Sole,
mentre la sfera rossa, quella più piccola,
rappresenta il fabbisogno di energia
di tutte le attività dell’uomo sulla Terra
per un anno.
La sfera verde rappresenta l’energia
che potremmo raccogliere col vento,
mentre quella grigia,
l’energia racchiusa in tutti i giacimenti
di carbone sulla Terra.
Il problema è come trasformare
la luce del Sole
in energia utile per le nostre città,
per le nostre automobili.
Oggi possiamo trasformare in modo efficace
l’energia del sole in elettricità
usando i pannelli solari.
Però non riusciamo ancora a immagazzinare
grandi quantità di energia nelle batterie.
E ancor di più, non riusciamo a ridurre
il consumo di combustibili fossili
per i processi industriali.
Per esempio, l’utilizzo del carbone
per la produzione dell’acciaio.
Utilizzare la luce del sole
è ancora una sfida aperta e importante.
I pannelli fotovoltaici stanno ricoprendo
i tetti delle nostre abitazioni ma ad oggi
solo il 10% dell’energia elettrica
nel mondo è prodotta in questo modo.
E poi dobbiamo ricordare
che solo il 20% dell’energia
che noi utilizziamo sulla Terra
è utilizzata sotto forma di elettricità.
Il rimanente 80% è costituito
dal consumo di una molecola
ovvero di un combustibile
principalmente di origine fossile
che utilizziamo per le navi,
gli aerei e per produrre l’acciaio.
Ebbene,
ci piacerebbe esistesse una molecola
capace di raccogliere la luce del sole
e sostituire i combustibili fossili.
Questa molecola esiste
ed è proprio l’idrogeno.
L’idrogeno è un gas,
è un gas combustibile
che ha tre caratteristiche fondamentali.
Può essere prodotto
in modo pulito dall’acqua.
Quando lo si usa non inquina.
Produce acqua, ritorna ad essere acqua
e non produce anidride carbonica.
È molto simile al gas naturale
e quindi si potrebbe derivare
dall’infrastruttura utilizzata
per il metano
le tubazioni e gli stoccaggi
per il suo utilizzo.
Oggi l’idrogeno è usato
come combustibile nelle automobili
in alternativa al gas naturale e al GPL.
Ma soprattutto l’idrogeno
potrebbe esserci utile per i cosiddetti
processi ad alta intensità energetica,
dove l’elettricità e le batterie
non possono essere utilizzati.
Pensate che per attraversare l’Atlantico
con una nave mossa da batterie
ci servirebbe trainare
un’altra nave carica di batterie.
Ma soprattutto l’idrogeno
può essere utile per fare l’acciaio,
lavorazione oggi responsabile del 10%
della produzione
di anidride carbonica mondiale.
L’idrogeno oggi può sostituirsi
quasi interamente al carbone,
e se l’idrogeno viene prodotto
da fonti rinnovabili,
con minima produzione
di anidride carbonica.
Ebbene, abbiamo trovato la molecola
per sostituire i combustibili fossili.
Il problema è che l’idrogeno verde,
quello prodotto da fonti rinnovabili,
costa ancora molto e la domanda è bassa.
Per ridurne il costo abbiamo bisogno
di aumentare contemporaneamente
domanda e offerta.
Questo può avvenire
sviluppando l’intera filiera a idrogeno
nell’area a destinazione limitata.
Queste aree oggi vengono chiamate
Hydrogen Valley o Valli dell’Idrogeno.
Come dire,
delle Silicon Valley dell’idrogeno
dove si concentrano risorse e competenze
al fine di portare sviluppo e benessere
nel pieno rispetto
della sostenibilità ambientale.
Queste aree sono ancora
in fase di sperimentazione.
L’obiettivo è quello di realizzarne
un numero sempre più grande
e poi di collegarle
in modo tale da estendere le regioni
nelle quali si abbandona
l’utilizzo di combustibili fossili
a favore delle energie rinnovabili.
Energie rinnovabili prodotte localmente
quindi limitando
la dipendenza da paesi lontani
con le conseguenti complicazioni e rischi.
Bene.
Qui in Friuli Venezia Giulia quest’anno
è stata costituita la prima Hydrogen
Valley a livello transnazionale in Europa,
assieme ai territori
di Slovenia e Croazia,
una zona in cui sviluppare
una forte economia di scala
e sfruttare le risorse della ricca
comunità scientifica dei territori.
Ma come funziona un’Hydrogen Valley?
Nelle Hydrogen Valley vengono prodotte
grandi quantità di energia elettrica
a partire dalle fonti rinnovabili,
come il sole, il vento.
Questa energia può essere subito
utilizzata per ricaricare le automobili
o per le città.
Ma soprattutto, l’energia elettrica può
essere utilizzata negli elettrolizatoni
degli impianti che consentono di
trasformare l’acqua, H2O,
in idrogeno, H2.
Ecco, quindi nell’Hydrogen Valley
abbiamo raccolto la luce del sole,
l’abbiamo trasformata nella molecola
che poi si trasforma in un combustibile
in alternativa al combustibile fossile
per alimentare
le acciaierie e cementifici.
L’idrogeno non immediatamente consumato
può essere immagazzinato
per un successivo utilizzo
per esempio quando
la luce del sole non ci sarà.
O può essere usato nelle navi, negli aerei
dove le batterie sarebbero
troppo pesanti e ingombranti.
L’Hydrogen Valley è quindi un ecosistema
nel quale le attività industriali
rimangono in esercizio,
ma vengono alimentate da energia pulita.
L’Hydrogen Valley è un progetto importante
ma per conseguire l’obiettivo
di neutralità climatica
e basso costo dell’energia
c’è ancora della strada da fare.
Dobbiamo investire in ricerca
sia per trovare nuove soluzioni
sia per migliorare
le tecnologie esistenti.
Oggi l’idrogeno sta sostituendo il carbone
e la mia macchinina
farebbe molta più strada
ma non tutti potrebbero averla.
Per averla tutti dobbiamo impegnarci
ed essere consapevoli che siamo
tutti parte del sistema energetico
e possiamo incidere su di questo
a partire dalle nostre scelte,
abitudini e azioni quotidiane.
Coniugando questo impegno
e la ricerca scientifica
lasceremo in eredità
alle nuove generazioni
un mondo con una qualità della vita
migliore e ricco di opportunità
garantendone,
allo stesso tempo, la sostenibilità.
Grazie. (applausi)